hier herzlich willkommen zur ersten
sitzung im neuen jahr und wir werden uns
heute erst mal mit der frage befassen
wie sie hausarbeiten schreiben können
sollen wenn sie wollen wer von ihnen hat
den vor nach hause reinzuschreiben
dessen relativ viele und haben sie alle
meinen merkblatt bekommen war sich um
geschickt hatte in der woche vor den
weihnachtsferien und ich geh jetzt also
heute kurz darauf ein und wehrte dann
ganz wie gewohnt auf den text der
heutigen sitzung eingehen und dem mit
ihnen diskutieren
wir haben aber ganz zu beginn haben wir
noch ein quiz das habe ich ihnen ja auch
ungeschickt und das wollen wir jetzt
noch zusammen gemeinsam lösen können sie
das lesen ja also wenn sie mal auffiel
lowcost punkt nicht gehen dann finden
sie dort auch zwei weitere gewisse
nämlich zum thema was ist zeit und zum
thema kausalität diese krise sind genau
so aufgebaut wie hier nur ist das wohl
der längste quiz oder das längste quiz
und jetzt machen wir einfach mal
zusammen also einmal service also worin
besteht nach harry frankfurt
willensfreiheit ist immer eine oder
mehrere antwortmöglichkeiten sind
richtig erste möglichkeit wir haben
wünsche zweiter ordnung wünschen muss
natürlich groß geschrieben werden zweite
option wir können volition zweiter
ordnung ausbilden von drittens wir
können uns wesentlich auf unser wollen
beziehen
das ist jetzt aber gar nicht so einfach
ich weiß es nämlich nicht mehr was jetzt
hier richtig und falsch ist was würden
sie sagen was ist richtig
ja
und warum nicht 1 ach so was haben sich
zwei und eins ist dass zwei und drei und
so genau warum nicht 1
ja also ich glaube dass hier sind in der
richtigen richtung also also frankfurt
sagt ja die person wird über ihre
willensfreiheit bestimmt und sie kennt
dieses beispiel wo frankfurt sagt es ist
denkbar dass es ein wesen gibt was
obwohl es wünsche zweiter ordnung
ausbildet dennoch keine koalitionen
zweiter ordnung hat also volition sind
immer handlungs wirksame wünsche also
wünsche die gewollt werden sozusagen
und es könnte sein dass es ein wesen
gibt was wünsche zweiter ordnung hat
aber keine koalitionen zweiter ordnung
und wie nennt frankfurt diese wesen
wissen sie das noch das ist dann ein ja
ein ponton genau wie schallte es mal hin
also das ist ein interessanter begriff
von frankfurt der von ihm geprägt wurde
finde ich ganz originell ich schreibe es
mal hin also ein
ein ponton jetzt schauen ob's stimmt
vielleicht stimmt es auch nicht aber ja
stimmt ja also das habe ich mir dabei
gedacht also wünsche zweiter ordnung ist
noch nicht person sein oder willens zu
sein
es ist eine evolution zweiter ordnung
gehen wir auf die nächste frage über was
versteht man unter liberianischer erste
möglichkeit freiheit und determinismus
sind kompatibel
zweite möglichkeit freiheit
determinismus sind inkompatiblen
kompatibel und der determinismus ist
falsch dritte möglichkeiten wir sind
frei weil der determinismus falsch ist
das ist gar nicht so einfach jetzt also
damit ist jetzt wie gesagt nicht die
politische position des liberalismus
gemeint sondern die freiheits
theoretische position und die nennen wir
eben ein bisschen länger liberta
realismus um es von liberalismus
abzugrenzen
der sus oder auch liberalismus
liberianische arianes dass der
unterschied also haben sie eine idee wie
sieht es mit 1 aus ist das lieber
terrorismus liberta realismus walten
der termin ist kompatibel wie würde man
diese positionieren
genau also kompatibel ismus und liberta
realismus sind nicht auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt auf derselben ebene wie
kompatibel ist muss ist die position des
inkompatibel ismus angelegt also das ist
es dann wohl eher nicht wie sieht es mit
der zweiten möglichkeit aus freiheiten
determinismus sind inkompatibel und
determinismus ist falsch
ja inkompatibel habe ich ja es richtig
also sind inkompatibel
dann ist es ein inkompatibel ist muss
aber hier kommt jetzt noch eine weitere
ein weiterer zusatz dazu und der termin
ismus ist falsch es ist es nicht nur ein
kompatibles muss sondern es ist ein
spezieller inkompatibel
ich mache mal folgendes als sie können
sich das so vorstellen sie haben ja eine
große menge
das ist die menge aller inkompatibel ist
ischen positionen dass hier das seien
alle positionen hier diese menge die
inkompatibel ist ish sind die also
behaupten dass ich freiheit und
determinismus nicht miteinander
vertragen
das ist ja unsere definition nach dem
kompatibel ist und jetzt kann man aber
hier innerhalb dieser menge der
inkompatibel ist ischen positionen zwei
mengen nochmal unterscheiden nämlich zum
einen den die batterie an is muss noch
eine menge
es gibt sie noch von der menge was
könnte ich noch von der position dar
einnehmen die inkompatibel ist ish ist
aber jetzt kein die berta realismus ist
die eben auch seien die tennis muss sind
gegen kontakt kompatibel aber daraus
folgt nicht dass der determinismus
falsch ist zum er dass der terminus muss
wahr ist und die freiheit falsch wir
nicht wie nennt man diese position dann
ja das wäre ein fall das ist richtig
dass er ein spezialfall eines
inkompatibel es muss aber der gängige
kompatibel ist muss ihm kompatibel ist
muss der sagt fremden determinismus oder
so sind inkompatibel aber determinismus
ist war die nennt man einfach
determinismus determinismus also ein
bisschen gefährlich wenn man von
inkompatibel ist muss redet denkt man
gleich man würde in determinismus
vertreten
also man sagt freiheiten determinismus
sind nicht kompatibel
dann liegt der kurzschluss nahezu sagen
ja gut dann gibt es keine freiheit wenn
beide inkompatibel sind aber und könnte
jetzt die option werden sagen nein bitte
determinismus ist falsch und weil
freiheit determinismus nicht kompatibel
sind folgt raus wenn du determinismus
falsch ist dann sind wir frei weil der
ja falsch unterbleibt blieben nur noch
die freiheit übrig wenn wir so von
dieser art stricken endlich für ausgehen
also mehrere jetzt nach dieser
klassifikation dann die zweite these
zutreffen
der zweite punkt zu treffen für liberta
realismus
wir sind knifflige
nach dem was wir jetzt hier gemacht
haben
ja genau also sind inkompatibel insofern
hatten sie recht ist es eine position
des inkompatibel ismus aber es ist noch
ein spezieller fall des inkompatibel
ismus weil es gibt eben zwei formen des
inkompetent meniskus den determinismus
und den liberta realismus es geht ihm um
die frage freiheit und determination
determinismus vertragen die sich
miteinander
die beiden freiheiten determinismus wenn
wenn man sagt ja wie nennt man dann die
position wenn man das bejaht dass sie
sich miteinander vertragen dann vertritt
man ein kompatibles muss wenn man sagt
nein dann vertritt mit 1 inkompatibel
ist aber die gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
man kann sagen das ist falsch
dann vertritt man hier einen
determinismus und wenn man sagt das ist
falsch und das ist richtig vertreten ein
journalismus
es ist ein bisschen kompliziert aber ich
glaube wir haben erklärt und dies mit
der dritten option also wir sind frei
weil der determinismus falsches
es werden
ja es ist richtig jetzt richtig denn sie
haben recht aber wenn man jetzt von
dieser strikten alternative ausgeht
entweder oder
also wenn man sagt es gibt nur die zwei
möglichkeiten freiheit oder
determinismus der termin ist muss es
wäre auch noch richtig aber sie haben
eigentlich recht also es gebe man könnte
sich überlegen gibt sich noch eine
dritte option freiheit und determinismus
und noch irgendwas mysterium zum
beispiel mysterium
aber ich glaube das ist jetzt steckt man
dass man das richtig also die sind
letztendlich nach meiner formulierung
letztendlich identisch diese zweite und
dritte option wenn wir die alternative
haben freiheit oder determinismus und
determinismus falsch ist dann ja
unterminiert
dann wird er eben auch falsch
genau zufälligkeiten determiniert würde
man sagen ja genau sie haben recht das
ist nicht ganz klar formuliert gewesen
haben sie mich haben sie in guten punkt
gemacht ja man könnte auch noch sagen
wir sind frei weil der in der termin
ismus war ist also aus der falschheit
des determinismus folgt nur dann der
libertarian is muss wenn man eben den in
der termin ist muss als falsch ansieht
dann sie recht also es gebe hier noch
die option in determinismus das richtig
also müsste man noch ein bisschen
spezifizieren nächste frage was versteht
man unter mysterien ismus frei
determinismus sind kompatibel
zweite möglichkeit freiheit ist ein
mysterium der determinismus war ist
freiheit und determinismus sind
inkompatibel und determinismus ist wahr
aber wir müssen uns dennoch als frei
verstehen aber wieder drüber diskutieren
die erste möglichkeit wäre ja ihr ein
kompatibles muss nur das würde man eher
als kompatibles muss bezeichnen als er
nicht mysteriös muss die zweite
möglichkeit wie sehen sie die jetzt ich
muss dazu sagen alles jetzt immer unter
dem dem grundsatz der prämisse freiheit
und determinismus schließen die optionen
aus na also unter dieser konjunktion
frei und determinismus bildtermin ismus
lassen wir's mal raus in determinismus
wie sie vielleicht schon in den
sitzungen vor weihnachten gesehen haben
spielt eigentlich nur eine ganz geringe
rolle
selbst lieber tahrir- am rahmen mit
diesem begriff des in determinismus ein
bisschen ihre probleme robert kenner
dieser philosoph der sich ein bisschen
mit dem in der termin ismus beschäftigt
hat freiheit ist ein mysterium der
determinismus war ist man müsse dazu
sagen und freiheit und determinismus
eigentlich inkompatibel sind würden sie
sagen ja oder nein ich weiß jetzt gerade
auch nicht mehr also unter der bedingung
dass freiheit und determinismus nicht
kompatibel sind immer noch tanzen wir
und let's und die dritte option freiheit
und determinismus sind inkompatibel und
determinismus ist wahr aber wir müssen
uns ja noch als verstehen
über tage
nämlich ganz weil der libertarian ismus
würde sagen der determinismus ist falsch
was würden sie sagen ja dann liegt
jemand also ja ich bin jetzt selbst auch
nicht mit der zweiten option sich also
die dritte ist irgendwie schon richtig
ja also da war ich auch nicht ganz
präzise man müsste die zweite position
eigentlich nur so formulieren dürfen wie
die dritte option weil es gibt ja noch
die position des intertainment es
maßnahmen auch wenn die so gut wie nie
irgendwie berücksichtigt wird nächste
frage worin unterscheiden sich wille und
wunsch voneinander persönlichkeit der
wille ist ein handlungs wirksamer wunsch
zweit möglichkeit wünsche können sich
auf die zukunft richten
der will nur auf die gegenwart wünsche
sind nicht handlungs wirksam
wer etwas will will auch die mittel zur
verwirklichung des wunsches das weiß sie
jetzt selbst gerade auch nicht auf
anhieb was ich mir da überlegt habe
wie sieht es mit der ersten option aus
ja sie nicken also der wunsch der
verbleibt nur so im allgemeinen
ich könnte mir dieses wünschen ich
könnte mir jenes wünschen ich wünschte
es wäre jetzt sommer ist das mein wille
das ist jetzt sommer ist und links mal
wenn sie so reden ich wünschte es wäre
jetzt sommer kann ein solcher wunsch
mein wille sein schütteln den kopf warum
nicht
man muss
oder ich wünschte ich wäre jetzt in den
usa
ich wünschte ich wäre jetzt in new york
jetzt in diesem moment da sehen sie es
geht nicht ich gehe es sei denn ich
leben der zukunft kann mich dann beamen
so jetzt nehme ich so von einer sekunde
auf die andere aber momentan geht das
nicht es kann auch sein dass würden
städte sind ganz interessanter fall dass
wünsche hinsichtlich ihrer handlungs
wirksamkeit zeitbedingt sind also manche
wünsche die menschen früher hatten die
nur wünsche seien konten können heute
zum willen werden und zwar deswegen weil
wir heute die möglichkeiten haben früher
sagt jemand ich wünschte ich wäre auf
dem mond vor 200 jahren geht es nicht
heute geht das schon also wer den willen
hat auf dem mond zu gehen der kann ihn
realisieren also ist möglich ist nicht
ausgeschlossen
wenn jetzt jemand zum beispiel gleich
und jetzt jemand der fünf milliarden
euro hinblättert und dann reichen also
sich an ein unternehmen wendet da kann
man zumindest meinen weltraum als auch
nicht 5 milliarden euro weniger also
kann man zumindest in den weltraum
fliegen ja das ging vor 200 jahren nicht
oder
wünsche er oder während das dann noch
munition oder nicht eher die sei es also
nach harry frank wird dass wir also
entgegengesetzte begehungen haben oder
wenn sie sagen der wille ist selbst
gespalten
genau das ist dieser fall dieser villen
spaltung bei harry frankfurt was würden
sie jetzt darauf reagieren auf diesen
fall der ist jedenfalls nicht handlungs
wirksam
das muss man sagen aber man würde sich
vielleicht schon sagen ich bin bereit
alle mittel ich wäre bereit alle mittel
zu ergreifen
aber ich kann sie halt nicht realisieren
als der wille der kann da nicht
handlungs wirksam werden das könnte man
vielleicht willensschwäche nennen oder
sowas
aber ein guter punkt da sie darauf
hinweisen als handlungs wirksam da
vielleicht nicht nur so verstanden
werden dass man es irgendwie könnte
sondern muss wirklich auch schon dann so
die die mittel so ergreifen
man muss da richtig schon dabei sein um
es zu machen deswegen würde ich auch
fast sagen es kann eigentlich gar nicht
mein wille sein jetzt auf dem auf den
mond zu fliegen weil das glaubt so
scheint mir doch noch zu sehr entfernt
ist also das sind zu viele umstände
notwendig dass dieser wille dieser
wunsch dass die realisiert werden kann
also sage ich sage mal von wille muss
müsste man vielleicht genau genommen so
sprechen dass es sich dabei um optionen
handelt die in einem näheren umkreis von
gegen also die nicht zu weit entfernt
sind ja je weiter der das ziel entfernt
ist und je mehr stationen sie
durchschreiten müssen um zu dem ziel zu
gelangen
umso weniger überblicken sie die mittel
die sie eben bedürfen der sie bedürfen
um den wunsch zu realisieren
sie müssten eigentlich scheint mir zu um
einen willen zu haben die ganzen mittel
überblicken und wieso einer kette also
ich sag mal so wunsch wunsch und hier
ist das ziel
da müssten sie so alle mittel müssten
sie hier alle zwischenschritte müssen
sie irgendwo auf einen schlag
überblicken und dann hätten sie den
wilden wenn diese kette zu lang ist hier
dann kann sich das wieder illusion
verfangen könnten sie da wieder nur so
ein hirngespinst haben
ich glaube dass das eine bedingung ist
dass der wille nur auf relativ nahe
stehende objekte gerichtet werden kann
ohne nur ein wunsch zu sein also bei
wünschen ist es so dass dessen die
wünsche betreffen objekte gegenstände
zustände die weit entfernt sind die
häufig räumlich zeitlich entfernt sind
zum beispiel auf dem mond zu zahlen oder
jetzt der usa zu sein aber darüber
können uns können sie auch gerne eine
hausarbeit schreiben
worin besteht der unterschied zwischen
wille und wunsch und sich dabei auf
harry wijnvoord beziehen
das wäre eine spannende frage weil es so
klar ist mir die unterscheidung jetzt
auch noch nicht
sie sehen also wenn man darüber
diskutiert kommt man gleich auf ganz
verschiedene schwierigkeiten zweite
option wünsche können sie auf die
zukunft richten
der wille nur auf die gegenwart als ich
jetzt auch nicht was würden sie sagen
wer nicht dritte wünsche sind nicht
handlungs wirksam
sie können handlungs wirksam sein wenn
sie gewollt wenn sie ein wenn sie ein
wille cent genau her
ich glaube dass ich sie ja dass ich so
gemeint hatte aber ich bin mir sicher
wer etwas will will auch die mittel zur
verwirklichung des wunsches ja also ich
bin mir wie gesagt jetzt auch nicht
sicher wie das mit dieser zukunft ist
was ich mir dabei gedacht habt oh ja es
richtig zu fall
ich wusste jetzt auch nicht mehr aber
das dritte ist problematisch haben sie
recht man kann sagen also wir könnten
das folgendermaßen machen wir könnten
sagen hier
das ist die menge aller wünsche und es
gibt jetzt hier
es gibt hier eine menge der wünsche der
potenziellen wünschen die ville werden
können so meinten sie das ne also wir
haben hier so eine größere menge dessen
wünsche und es gibt eine teilmenge das
sind 1 handlungs wirksame wünsche und
das andere wehren dass wir also
handlungs wirksam
zusammen und das wäre eben nicht
handlungswillig
nicht handlungswillig aber wenn man es
ein bisschen allgemeiner ließ dann denke
ich kann man auch sagen wünsche als
solche sind noch nicht per se handlungs
wirksam da muss noch was dazukommen es
muss ein spezieller wunsch sein aber ein
großer wunsch ist nicht handlungswillig
sein wenn man so liest er das okay aber
sie haben recht
[Musik]
ja als er sagt er dann der wille kommt
dann zustande wenn die koalition zweiter
stufe handlungs wirksam sind als ich so
auf unsere erst stufigen willens
tendenzen richten dass die als gewollt
werden und dann zu einer handlung führen
eine gute frage ob man die koalition
zweiter stufe schon als wille bezeichnet
ich würde sagen wenn die handlungs
wirksam sind ja wenn die sich so auf den
willen erster stufe die wolle die
willens tendenzen erster stufe beziehen
dass sie handlungsfähig sein werden
dann würde ich sie in bielen ja die
position zweiter stufe insofern die
handlungs wirksam werden
ja aber ist eine spannende frage und
darüber kann man wie gesagt ein sehr gut
eine hausarbeit schreiben was versteht
man unter inkompatibel ist muss erste
möglichkeit wenn der determinismus war
ist sind wir nicht frei man ist sie
vielleicht sagen was für eine form ist
ist es ist inkompatibel ismus zwei
optionen wenn wir frei sind ist der
determinismus falsch dritte möglichkeit
handlungsfreiheit und willensfreiheit
sind nicht kompatibel vierter
möglichkeit freiheit und determinismus
sind nicht kompatibel
option wie steht es damit ist es
beschreibt die erste der erste satz die
erste these beschreibt die die position
des inkompatibel zu nicken
zweiter sagen sie auch wenn wir frei
sind ist determinismus falsch und wie
sieht es mit der dritten option aus
nicht genau das wäre so ein also so
redet man gewöhnlich nicht von
inkompatibel ist muss man redet von
ihnen kompatibel
das muss nur mit blick auf freiheit und
determinismus ich hatte ja einmal so ein
bisschen die option ins spiel gebracht
gibt es nicht auch ein kompatibles muss
oder inkompatibel ismus mit blick auf
den in den termin es muss ja zum
beispiel wäre arbeit kann ein kompakt
kompatibel ist von freiheit und eben
determinismus aber so redet niemanden
man spricht immer nur von kompatibel
ismus oder inkompatibel ismus mit blick
auf die position des determinismus
versus freiheit also der in
determinismus ist nicht eine position
die deren bejahen oder verneinen zu
einem kompatibles muss guten kompatibles
muss führt direkt als indirekt schon
aber man spricht immer über den
determinismus also die dritte option so
redet man gewöhnlich nicht von ihm
kompatibel ismus und die vierte sagten
sie ja freunde determinismus sind nicht
kompatibel checken wir das mal oder gibt
es gegen rehden einwände hätte mir das
mal also ich hab das jedenfalls ähnlich
gesehen
das heißt nicht dass es richtig sein
muss aber es hat schon was versteht man
unter willensfreiheit anders wollen
können tun können was man will wollen
können was man will wollen können was
man soll
wie sieht es mit der ersten option aus
anders wollen können sie nicken
wollen sie eine kurze begründung geben
oder leute ihnen ist einfach so ungefähr
also alternative möglichkeiten nicht nur
des handelns ist dann auch des wollens
das okay der wille ist nicht nur fixiert
tun können was man will ist das ein fall
von willensfreiheit eine beschreibung
von willensfreiheit nein warum nicht
das ist handlungsfreiheit dritte option
wollen können was man will
sie nicken ja sie sind richtig sie
liegen richtig ist ist doch klar ist
offensichtlich klar obwohl es ein
bisschen paradox eigentlich formuliert
ist wollen können was man will wenn man
etwas will
dann will man das doch nicht noch mal
selbst obwohl eigentlich schon aber wenn
man was will denn er hat man doch schon
genug gewollt ist dass man das dann noch
wollen können das ist doch eigentlich
unnötig könnte man sagen wenn ich etwas
will dann will ich das und wieso sollte
ich dann nochmal wollen können so wird
john locke argumentieren auf den wir
heute eingehen er wird sagen die idee
der willensfreiheit die ist eigentlich
sinnlos wir sind dann frei wenn wir tun
können was wir wollen
john lobb versteht deswegen freiheit
sehr von der kraft her also von der
realisierung john bock hat deswegen
tendenziell es mache ich schon eine
kleine vorwegnahme tendenziell eher eine
position von handlungsfreiheit als
handelsfreien obwohl sich bayern block
ansätze von willensfreiheit auch finden
wie wir noch sehen wird wollen können
was man soll sie schütteln den kopf
warum nicht und was spricht für sie
dagegen
ja genau
ja genau also ich gebe mir da teilweise
zu es ist nur so dass diese wendung von
leibnitz stammt und leibnitz bestimmt
wiese wenn du als fall von
willensfreiheit aber man muss sich
wirklich fragen mal kommt das sollen
wenn man als man vielleicht ist hier
ganz hilfreich sich das sollen vom
müssen zu unterscheiden
also wollen können was man muss wenn ich
etwas muss will ich das dann also müssen
ist dann stark der termin ist muss aber
wenn man was man soll sollen ist ja
nicht gleich müssen also sollen ist ja
nur ich kann auch anders
ich soll es so also wenn ich etwas soll
dann kann ich es auch gut ich kann es
nicht
das ist der vortrag von peter pan in
welchen gewesen also die frage sollen
können oder nicht können würden sie
sagen dass es daraus folgt wenn ich
etwas soll folgt daraus dass ich es auch
kann oder auch nicht kann nicht können
kann und sich genauer sagen dass ich das
ist kann folgt es für sich daraus
eine abstimmung wer meint dass aus
sollen können folgt einfach mal melden
und auch nicht können gemacht ja und wer
meint dass es nicht raus folgt mal die
argumente derjenigen die glauben es
folgen nicht raus wenn möchte jemand
stellung
warum glauben manche von ihnen das aus
dem sollen nicht das können folgt wollen
sie was sagen haben sie ein argument ja
man muss ja sollen von müssen und das
scheint ja aber zählen zb sollen du
sollst nicht töten so und gebot du
sollst nicht stehlen sagen wir sollten
nicht steht
das ist ein sollen daraus folgt ich kann
dieses gebot befolgen
ich kann es aber auch nicht vor
[Musik]
die situation schon gute zahlen muss
ja genau aber dann muss man ja praktisch
nein man muss ja dann eigentlich wenn
man nicht das tut dann kommt man ins
gefängnis oder unter bestimmten
situation wird vielleicht auch getötet
dann wäre das ja nicht mehr der kontakte
sollen schon eigentlich genau genommen
der kontext des müssens wahnsinnig sagen
oder
wobei das interessante ist dieses gebot
du sollst nicht töten heißt eigentlich
im original im hebräischen original gar
nicht du sollst nicht töten
es gibt in der bibel gar kein aus dem
hebräischen christlichen bibel gar kein
tötungs und das verbot
ungerechtfertigter weise zu töten
also du sollst nicht morden steht da
nicht du sollst nicht töten ist auch
interessant deswegen habe ich jetzt
dieses beispiel des stillens gebracht
du sollst nicht stehlen sicherlich ein
gebot das ist die gesetze sagen dass
unsere moral sagt das dass wir nicht
stehen sollen
aber natürlich kann ich mal was spielen
und natürlich kann ich also ich kann es
natürlich auch aber ich kann es
natürlich auch nicht aber die logik ist
die die tatsache dass ich überhaupt soll
also wenn das bejaht wird soll ich und
wenn man das bringt ja ich soll das ist
war es gebe jetzt eine objektive moral
stellen sie mir vor unabhängig ob es so
etwas geben kann
aber stellen sie mal vor es gäbe eine
objektive moral die objektive geltung
hätte denken sie an kants kategorischen
imperativ
das gilt einfach so sagt das kann diese
kategorische imperativ handel es so sie
kennen alle die formulierung die gelte
jetzt mal objektiv haben zwar alle
zweifel aus die geld und wenn die gilt
also wenn das wahr ist dann ist jetzt
die frage ist dann auch das können oder
anders können war
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass dieses
sollen objektiv das würden sie sagen ja
dann nein sie immer noch nicht ja was
hätte dagegen sprechen
das weihnachtsgeschäft ist riskant dass
er als bisher und das ist im grunde
standhalten zusteht wenn diese objektive
dann könnte man sich eben fragen muss da
nicht im generellen sinne als ein
letzter and letzte hin sich gedacht muss
man da nicht in das sollen durch das
müssen ersetzen aber eine spannende
fragen ob dieses sollen auch solche
fälle von zwang aufhebt
also fiel ja sie noch hier
zu lassen
bruder punkt guter punkt so könnte man
es auch sehen ich denke dann würden auch
die meist zustimmen alle die meisten
dieser wenn nur dann wenn wir
willensfreiheit voraussetzen
dann können wir auch empfänglich für
moralische gebote sein dass ich glaube
da würde jeder zustimmen die frage ist
jetzt eben andersherum wenn wir das
sollen setzen wenn wir ein möglicher
adressat des sollens sind wenn an uns
sollens gebote gerichtet werden können
wenn das gerechtfertigter weise
geschieht
die frage ist halt setzt die tatsache
des sollens gebotes nicht schon implizit
voraus dass wir frei sind
weil sonst wäre das ja sinnlos ich kann
ja nur jemanden etwas im modus des
sollens befehlen wenn ich impliziere
dass er auch es kann weil sonst wäre ja
ein gebot zynisch stellen sie mir vor an
uns ginge ein gebot irgendetwas zu tun
oder nicht zu tun
angebot und ein verbot aber wir können
das gar nicht befolgen das wäre ein
zynisches gebot
also es geht also ich will das jetzt gar
nicht entscheiden ich will nur sagen es
gibt eben solche und solche argumente
viele sagen aber das kann man bestreiten
wir sie ja auch gemacht haben dass wände
das sollen gerechtfertigt ist da ist
dann damit impliziert ist dass wir frei
sind
also das sind das aus dem süden sollen
das können folgt weil sonst das sollen
keinen wirklichen sinn hätte aber man
kann das durchaus problematisiert und
harry und peter fand in regen hat in
seinem vortrag eben dieses ist also ort
ist das englische wort und das ist mehr
oder camp das ist dass das ort und das
ist immer die frage darüber ging auch
der vortrag ich verlinke den noch mal an
dieser stelle jetzt hier in dieser
aufzeichnung des seminars
ok also das ist nur wollen können was
man soll eben leibnitz sagt ja das ist
eine beschreibung von wilms zeit aber
man kann das auch problematisieren
vorletzte frage was versteht man unter
handlungsfreiheit wollen können was man
soll wollen können was man tut wollen
können was man will tun können was man
will also wie sieht es mit der ersten
option aus
das ist er soll erfahrung der
willensfreiheit hatten ja gesehen wenn
man das akzeptiert wollen können was man
tut
da muss jetzt auch belegen
wir sehen wie stehen sie zur zweiten
option ist das eine form von
handlungsfreiheit wollen können was man
tut
auch wenn zwei dritte option wollen
können was man will war willens war
willensfreiheit und tun können was man
will
das ist dann generell ja die
handlungsfreiheit als man denkt eben
häufig willens wahrheit sei tun können
was man will
es ist so da ist man gleich beim tun
können und wollen gleich bei hall
willensfreiheit aber so ist es nicht das
ist eben nur handlungsfreiheit tun
können was man will
letzte frage was ist nach harry
frankfurt ein ponton
wir sind zu beginn der sitzung darauf
kurz eingegangen ein wesen dem seine
wünsche egal sind
ein wesen das keine wünsche hat ein
wesen das wünsch zweiter struktur
ausbildet dies aber nicht so position
zweiter stufe erhebt
also eins nicht
ja und wie sieht es mit der dritten
option aus also ich glaube ich hatte mit
der drei überlegt aber sie haben ja
versuche es mal ja weil das ist ja das
würde ja aus drei folgen also aus der
dritten option würde eigentlich so ein
bisschen folgen dass ihm auch die
wünsche egal sind oder wenn sie dich
sagen aus drei folgt 1 oder so das einst
volk 3 also jedenfalls die erste option
wäre es ohne nähere wäre so die
konklusion aus 3
ja schau mal richtig aber wie gesagt sie
sehen alle diese punkte ist kann man
diskutieren ja also wenn man in der
termin is muss dann noch mit dem spiel
bringt wir haben 18 von 18 punkten
toll so jetzt sind wir bestens gewidmet
gewappnet um hier weiter zu machen
nämlich mit unseren hinweisen zu hause
arbeiten
ich mache das jetzt recht schnell also
wenn sie fragen haben stellen sie die
gerne jetzt also sie könnten mit mir per
e-mail besprechen in der sprechstunde in
der nächste woche wahrscheinlich wieder
sprechstunde an
ich werde ihn auch noch eine liste mit
möglichen themen für hausarbeit fragen
zugänglich machen die arbeit das ist ja
hier ein bachelor seminar obwohl es ein
sehr anspruchsvolles seminar ist wie sie
ja schon gemerkt haben könnte man auch
ohne probleme zu einem master seminar
erklären
da es aber ein bachelor seminar ist nur
müssen sie nur 25.000 zeichen in ihrer
hausarbeit schreiben inklusive
leerzeichen
das sind circa zehn bis zwölf seiten und
sie sollten bitte die hausarbeit am 25
märz 2009 10 spätestens um 23 59 bei mir
abgeben wie ist das möglich
nur dann wenn sie es per e-mail ton und
zwar an diese e mail adresse hier und
zwar im pdf-format und betreffzeile
geben sie einfach hier
dieses
an der eigenständigkeit erklärung noch
am ende dazu nicht scannen können sie
einfach gezeichnet schreiben und dann
ist das ausreichend
falls sie krank sein sollten müssen sie
eben ein attest beim prüfungsamt
einreichen das haben sie aber alles
schon gesagt bekommen wenn irgendwas
ganz unerwartetes dazwischen kompass
jetzt nicht mit einer krankheit zu tun
hat können sie mit wir nochmal reden
darüber aber ich kann eben dann keine
besonders langen verlängerungsfrist mehr
gewähren
schriftgröße 12 times new roman fußnote
schriftgröße 10 im haupttext 1,5 facher
zeitabstand und in den fußnoten nur
einfacher zeilenabstand seitenzahl bitte
auch nicht vergessen und am besten blogs
satz aber das ist nicht so wichtig bitte
untersuchen sie die arbeit gründlich auf
rechtschreibfehler und vor allem auch
auf kommasetzung kommt immer vor weil
das 2 obwohl da in dem die kommas
strukturieren den text wenn sie sätze
mit weil das wohl da und so weiter
einsetzen dann zeigen sie dass sie
bestimmte ordnung slogan voneinander
unterscheiden können um die kommas sind
die indikatoren dafür dass es eine
logische modale unterscheidung
eingeführt wird zb konzession obwohl
kausal wäre weil da ist auch kausal in
dem wäre ihr modell dass sie solche
unterscheidungen eben mit komm ass
machen
das titelblatt interessanter titel
untertitel wählen das ist eine kunst
obertitel portiert werden nicht zu lang
kann aber auch gerne zitat sein
untertitel hier ein bisschen länger und
bisschen nicht so könnt ihr zum ersten
des crypt tiefer also was machen sie
jetzt da zum beispiel können sie auch
ein zitat will ja also wir jetzt mal
spielt john block sagt der wille ist
nicht frei oder sagen wir es so was dann
könnte das auch als zitat nehmen für den
artikel
dann geben sie auf dem titelblatt noch
informationen zu ihrer person an und
datum und so weiter
artikelnummer bitte auch dass wir auch
ganz wichtig dann beginnen sie die
arbeit mit einem inhaltsverzeichnis und
das besteht das zeigt eben dann die
einleitung hauptteil und schluss der
hauptteil wird immer untergliedert in
weitere punkte am schluss noch ein
literaturverzeichnis und jetzt ist mir
was ganz wichtig dass sie dieses
inhaltsverzeichnis sich bitte
automatisch erstellen lassen über die
option formatvorlagen weiß jeder von
ihnen wie das geht einfach mal melden
wer es weiß ist nicht alles nicht
schlimm weil ich nämlich geplant habe
über diese art und weise wie man eine
hausarbeit meinen seminaren zumindest
den allermeisten seminaren formatiert
ein video noch machen werde und zwar ein
screencast wissen sie was ein screencast
ist das ist also letztendlich die pure
puren ereignisse die sich auf meinem
desktop abspielen also ich werde
praktisch dann sich sehen dann einen
mauszeiger wie ich mit dem mauszeiger
dann also da oben auf word clique und
dann hier dieses markiere das sehen sie
als als ob sie selbst den monitor vor
sich hätten
das will ich mal versuchen ich habe
nämlich ein programm mit dem das auch
geht dann machen sie einen machen sie
literatur nachweis entweder in fußnoten
oder auch in klammern direkt hinter dem
zitat und sie können auch wenn sie
längere werke zitieren kurztitel
verwenden wie zb kpv kritik der
praktischen vernunft
sie sollten aber diese kurztitel immer
entweder in der ersten fußnote oder am
ende im literaturverzeichnis in einem
sogenannten sie klemmt verzeichnis
auflösen dass man eben weiß wofür steht
jetzt dieses kürzel in der einleitung
das ist das allerwichtigste in der
einleitung sollten sie eine
systematische slide problem
eine lite frage aufwerfen ein problem
viele hausarbeiten die schreiben nur in
denen wird nur sehr vage geschrieben
also schon lockt sagt dass dann sagt er
das dann sagte dass das ist nicht
schlecht sicherlich aber es ist eben
nicht im strengen sinne philosophisch
philosophisch heißt dass sie das was da
jemand sagt dass sie das immer
problematisieren also sie spielen sich
fragen warum sagt er das und wenn er das
sagt ist das plausibel
sie sollten bei den bloßen texten
zitaten bleiben sind sollten die zitate
immer in einen größeren zusammenhang
einordnen
der größte zusammen kann kein sein eine
ganz spezielle frage eine ganz
spezifische frage dass sie nach etwas
ganz spezifischen suchen und wurde der
größere zusammenhang kann unter anderem
sein dass sie das was da gesagt wird
problematisieren also eben nicht nur
paraphrasieren sondern am anfang
perspektiven und wichtig ist mir auch
dass sie eine argumentative struktur
hier versuchen
herauszuarbeiten also es geht immer um
argumente warum sagt jetzt schon lockt
das und das ist doch paradox auf den
ersten blick
und wie kann man das besser verstehen
dass sie auch so eine art von gedanken
kann am ende entwickeln
zitate sprechen nie für sich wenn sie
noch so interessant klingen sein zitat
sollten sie immer merken sollen aus
sollen voll können sollten sie immer
einleiten und auch kommentieren
einbeziehen
als beleg für eine these vernehmen also
nicht als selbstzweck des zitats in das
zitat immer nur als mittel zum zweck
sie wollen jetzt da ihre these belegen
dann bringen sie das zitat das die tat
muss eine funktion erfüllen die sich
nach ihrer ausbildung richtet also im
letzte hinrichtung im hauptteil können
sie dann eben noch weitere unterpunkte
einführen 2.1 2.2 2.3 und den
unterpunkten jeweils noch eine
überschrift geben also bekommen eben
eine gliederung ebene mehrere ordnungen
also hauptteil einleitung und
schlussteil sind auf der ebene 1
angesiedelt und der hauptteil hat dann
verschiedene punkte die der ebene 2
entsprechen nämlich 2.1 2.2 2.3 wenn es
sein muss können sie auch in die dritte
gliederung ebene hinabsteigen oder
hinaufsteigen wie auch immer 2.1.1 2.1
punkt 2
das ist in der regel für eine bloße
bachelor hausarbeit zu viel
also ich glaube sie kommen mit drei oder
vier gliederung punkte auf der zweiten
ebene im hauptteil damit kommen sie hin
aber das ist erfahrungssache das kann
man nicht generell sagen dass richtet
sich danach wie hier leitfrage sie eben
gewählt haben weil wenn sie zu viele
gliederung punkte wählen sei es jetzt
auf der zweiten ebene oder sei es auf
der dritten ebene haben sie das problem
dass sie dann im rahmen von zwölf seiten
geben nur noch eine halbe seite zu einem
gliederung punkt schreiben können und da
jeder gliederung punkt ein argument
enthalten sollte oder mehrere argumente
kann das unter umständen zu kurz sein
also ein argument braucht ein gedanke
braucht immer einen gewissen raum um
sich zu entfalten und deswegen würde ich
mal sagen bleiben sie auf so drei bis
vier punkten auf der zweiten ebene
wenn sie dann meine haut eine
bachelorarbeit schreiben oder eine
masterarbeit dann können sie natürlich
auf die dritte gliederung des ebene
gehen in meiner bachelorarbeit diese 30
seiten hat 30 bis 40 hat ja auch schon
bachelorarbeiten 50 70 zeiten da können
sie dann unter umständen vielleicht zehn
oder 81 punkte haben und davon
vielleicht zwei oder drei auf der
dritten ebene
und so wie das eben weiter je
umfangreicher die arbeit wird dann an
literaturverzeichnis und da wäre mir
wichtig dass sie dass sie primär
literatur und in sekundärliteratur
unterteilen hat jeder von ihnen meine
links bekommen mit dem pdf dateien die
sie verwenden können per dropbox link
hat es jeder bekommen also da werde ich
immer wieder wenn sie keine e-mail
bekommen von mir regelmäßig dann
schreiben sie mir weil dann
wahrscheinlich ihre e mail wieder falsch
aufgenommen haben oder sie bei ihnen im
spam-ordner gelandet ist oder ihr e mail
fach voll ist da gibt es ganz
verschiedene möglichkeiten
dann schreiben sie mir also in der
dropbox finden sie regelmäßig
aktualisiert in einem ordner primär
literatur finden sie alle originaltexte
und es ist immer so ein bisschen vage
sache was jetzt primär literatur was
sekundärliteratur ist
er ist jetzt harry frankfurts text
primär literatur ja wohl schon wenn
jetzt harry frankfurt sich intensiv mit
kants philosophie auseinandersetzen
würde wäre es dann immer noch primär
literatur oder nicht sekundärliteratur
weil es über ein anderes mehr geht weil
henry ford so bekannt ist zu bedeutend
ist würden viele sagen egal über wen
harry frank vertreibt ist bleibt primär
literatur
während wenn ich jetzt über harry
frankfurt schreibe dann ist das herz der
literaturen im besten sinne her noch
ganz auch mal ändern aber also die
unterscheidung zwischen primär und
sekundär literatur ist fließend ich
helfe ihnen ich komme ihm entgegen indem
ich eben in die ordner jeweils das rein
kopiere ich glaube aber auch dass für
unsere zwecke eigentlich nur primär
literatur genügt nämlich diese denker
die wir hier in diesem seminar behandeln
und dazu zähle neben harry frankfurt
robert kane später fand ihn wegen dann
eben die ganzen historischen positionen
augoustinos thomas von aquin aristoteles
und jetzt eben john locke man erkannt
und so weiter zu sagen aber sie können
natürlich auch sekundärliteratur nehmen
wir jetzt zum beispiel
forschungsliteratur die sich jetzt auf
die theorie von jon lord bezieht
grundsätzlich möchte ich aber sagen dass
es sich empfiehlt gerade zu beginn auch
wenn man sich da nicht so sicher ist mit
den texten dass man nicht gleich auf die
sekundärliteratur übergeht was dass es
den ein problem worin besteht das
problem wenn sie gleich zu beginn ihrer
arbeit auf die sekundärliteratur agieren
überlegen sie mal was könnte daran
problematisch sein
haben sie den warum könnte das schwierig
sein ja
genau also man gibt sich zu schnell in
eine abhängigkeit zu anderen thesen ja
da wird einem dann schon alles
abgenommen
dann sagt nur das was die da aber
schreibt das klingt aber interessant und
dann gebe ich eigentlich nur wieder was
diese philosophien darüber gesagt hat
und mache mir keine eigenen gedanken
mehr dazu
deswegen ist es immer sinnvoll erst mal
versuchen eigene these zu entwickeln
eigenen zugang herzustellen und von
diesem zugang aus an dieser dieser
perspektive die man auf den text hat von
dieser perspektive aus dann in die
sekundärliteratur erst zu gehen wenn man
schon ein bisschen eigene gedanken sich
gemacht haben so zitiert man aber auch
da können sie dann können sie auch
anders vorgehen es sollte einfach
vollständig seine ist nachname dann vor
nahm dann der titel des buches ort und
die arten verlags namen brauchen nicht
auf anzugeben das ist nicht notwendig
und dann noch ganz wichtig mir bitte
nicht aus wikipedia zitieren ich sage
mal ganz allgemein wikipedia ist
eigentlich nicht schlecht aber wikipedia
ist die stufe bevor sie dann zitieren
oder anders gesagt die stufe bevor sie
einen wirklich zitierfähigen text finden
weil sie manchmal in wikipedia gute
verweise auf sekundärliteratur finden
aber dass wikipedia als solches ist noch
kein zitierfähige text und jetzt frage
ich sie warum warum sollten sie nicht
nach wikipedia zitieren zu sagen weil es
schlecht ist genügt nicht weil der
weiter nur quatsch drinsteckt es gibt
nämlich nicht weil nämlich manche texte
manche wikipedia-artikel besser sind als
manche texte die sie als zitierfähig
eigentlich kategorisieren mögen es gibt
manche texte sind dort wirklich besser
wissenschaftlich besser als so genannte
wissenschaftlich gedacht warum sollten
sie dennoch nicht wie peter zitieren da
gibt es einen ganz einfachen grund es
ist eher ein formaler grund ist es gar
nicht so sehr ein innehalten sehr großen
formaler ja
es geht in die richtige richtung es geht
die richtige richtung wikipedia ist
mittlerweile so komplex dass sie
eigentlich jede version dokumentieren
können also es gibt wenn sie mal schauen
wer von ihnen hatten schon haupt bei
wikipedia selbst mitgewirkt bestimmt
oder noch nicht mal nicht noch nie
irgendwie mal was korrigiert oder mal
kleine verleumdung reingeschrieben oder
nicht eine kleine verleumdung
ausgenommen besser gesagt wir sind ja
hier alle anständige philosophin und
philosophen noch nicht also ich habe
schon oft gemacht natürlich nur
korrigiert da mal geburtsdatum
korrigiert da mal klein verweis auf mein
neues buch eingebaut und so und so und
haben das ist nicht das problem die
ganzen version kann man sehen man sieht
also wirklich jedes jedes komma was
entnommen wurde wird dokumentiert sie
können nach dieser version zitieren das
nicht das problem sondern das problem
ist sie wissen nicht wer die autoren
oder der autor mit klarnamen ist diesen
text zu verantworten hat und am ende
sind sie ja so viele wenn sie da alle
autoren da jetzt keine mit klarnamen das
würde ihn niemand zu lassen die wollen
ja alle anonym bleiben sondern auch
völlig okay aber sie hätten da ein
riesen ein riesen anzahl von autorinnen
autoren vielleicht mal so einen großen
artikel vielleicht 20 das ist völlig
unüblich und sie wissen nicht wem jetzt
was zuzuschreiben ist das können sie
schon rekonstruieren am ende können sie
alles feststellen wir jetzt was zu
verantworten hat aber das ist dass es
nicht nicht mehr macht bahn hat und die
autoren sind in der regel eben nicht
wissenschaftler im strengen sinne obwohl
ich hier auch nicht so streng wäre aber
sie sehen ist das prinzip von wikipedia
ist die anonymität
das prinzip von wikipedia ist aber trotz
des prinzips zur anonymität das prinzip
des kritischen austausches obwohl
wikipedia von anonymen autoren verfasst
wird größtenteils heißt es nicht dass da
jeder schreiben kann was er will und
dass am ende quatsch raus kommt zu einem
gegenteil da kommen meistens ziemlich
gute sachen aus weil sich die an
nomen autorinnen autoren selbst
kontrollieren
es ist ein kommunikativer prozess ein
demokratischer prozess wo eben auch
problematische inhalte sofort gemeldet
werden und nicht nur problematische
inhalte ich hatte mal versucht zum
artikel zu erstellen
über ein ganz spezielles thema das wurde
nicht zugelassen von einem bot also da
ist eine künstliche intelligenz dahinter
die sagt an wenn ich darüber ein artikel
schreiben möchte dann wird das entweder
erlaubt nicht erlaubt und zwar deswegen
weil das thema nicht relevant ist oder
weil es im gefüge der anderen artikel
nicht reinpasst da ist also so
automatisiert was durchaus gutes aber
trotz dieser guten mechanik ist es eben
nicht zitierfähig weil hier der autor
die autorin fehlt die für den artikel
gerade stehen muss die verantwortung zu
übernehmen hat und das ist ein prinzip
der wissenschaft dass man das an eine
person bindet die das zu verantworten
hat also autorschaft stichwort
autorschaft der gedanke der autor
schafft tritt bei wikipedia in den
hintergrund finde ich auch ganz gut es
sind demokratische prinzip da kommt sich
mehr darauf an auf ein auto auf eine
ehre es geht hier um ein gemeinsames
werken werkeln auf hohem niveau nur hass
das eben nicht zu unserem bisherigen
konzepte wissenschaft es kann sein dass
ich die wissenschaft in 100 jahren in
diese richtung entwickelt finde ich gar
nicht schlecht da das ist es gut
wikipedia aber momentan ist es eben das
ist ein riesen debatte ich werde im
nächsten semester in seminar anbieten
bieten über dieses phänomen der
digitalisierung und der digitalen welt
was damit alles einhergeht
aber das ist jetzt eben nicht gegenstand
dieses seminar ist
kennen sie alle wahrscheinlich noch
peter müllers philosophie lexikon
weekend denn das peter nüesch man hört
ja das ist auch was man sofort findet
ganz interessant auch nicht schlecht
aber selbst wenn da der peter müller
hinter steht nicht zitieren weil dieses
werk eben gar nicht auch aus eigener
sicht einen wissenschaftlichen anspruch
erhebt sondern es eben peter müllers
sicht der dinge aus einer bestimmten
perspektive heraus aber eben nicht aus
einer
sagen jetzt mal im strengen sinne
wissenschaftlichen betrachtung heraus
ich will das gar nicht schlecht reden
das ist hochinteressant und es ist auch
so als erste ideengeber sehr gut aber es
ist nicht geeignet um zitiert zu werden
und so sollten sie mit allen texten im
internet sehr vorsichtig sein sollten
wir am besten doch auf einschlägige
publikationen verweisen zeitschriften
bücher in etablierten verlage
achten sie darauf dass sie nicht
plagiieren ich sag das deswegen weil man
im seltensten fall bewusst sehenden
auges plagiiert sondern derjenige und
diejenige die plagiiert tut das
letztendlich am ende unbewusst das ist
nie ist aller seltensten fällen so dass
ich jetzt sage okay dieser gedanke ist
toll ich bin ich draufgekommen egal
merkt niemand ich schreibe jetzt ab das
ist in den seltensten fällen so
und wenn sie mal die größten plagiatoren
unserer zeit betrachten den namen kennen
sie alle
und dann mal überlegen wie dieses werk
zustande kam dann werden sie feststellen
dass diese gute herr am ende seine
dissertation auf einigen tcs
gleichzeitig geschrieben hat also der
hatte dann tc an diesem ort zu hause und
dort ein pc und da disketten und deine
version das heißt der hat im überblick
verloren natürlich war da sicherlich
auch eine fahrlässigkeit
hinter ich will das jetzt nicht alles
irgendwie entschuldigen aber das war
wohl nicht so dass er sich hingesetzt
hat uns erklärt
so und jetzt mache ich hier das größte
plagiat der politikgeschichte sind er
war einfach letztendlich nachlässig er
hat seine schreibarbeit nicht genug
kontrolliert ja der hat nicht genug
nachgeschaut ist die quelle jetzt
wirklich von mir habe ich die quelle
jetzt nachgewiesen oder nicht ja der war
nicht sorgfältig genug am ende wenn man
dann denkt acht dieser dieser gedanke
ist so toll
der muss von mir stammen also das kann
nicht sein dass ich den woanders her
also quellennachweis löschen
der ist von mir
ist doch klar das ist so toll das ist
von mir das kennt jeder von ihnen also
nicht kennen sie jedenfalls
aber da eben sich selbst kontrollieren
und selbst ebenso zu disziplinieren dass
man auch wenn man da einen tollen
gedanken findet dass die dann nicht
unbedingt von einem selbst stand muss ja
nicht schlimm als immer markieren und
nachweisen
so haben sie noch fragen
als wichtigste ist dass in den light
frage aufwerfen dass sie den text
problematisieren das tun sie in der
einleitung erstmal beginnen sie mit
kritischen fragen mit problemen die sich
ihnen gestellt haben im ausgang dieses
textes und versuchen sie den jeweiligen
text immer auf ein systematisches
problem hin zu lesen und das haben wir
ja hier im seminar zu genüge bisher
getan also determinismus in der termin
ist muss kompatibles muss und so weiter
sofort mysterien ist john law kein
mysterium ist könnten sie zum beispiel
fahren ist natürlich nicht aber so was
in dieser art also zum beispiel war es
immer gut ist es dann zu fragen zb bei
sherlock vertritt john law keine theorie
der willensfreiheit das finde ich ganz
spanien will ich auch jetzt dem nächsten
aufsatz zu verschneiden planen ich schon
seit mehreren jahren war schon lockt
immer nur als sohn willens als und
handlungsfreiheit theoretiker gelesen
wird und da können sie mal gegen so eine
gängige these argumentieren schon lockt
gilt gemeinhin als ein vertreter der
handlungsfreiheit und ich möchte ihnen
diese hausarbeit jetzt mal zeigen dass
er eigentlich ein theoretiker willens
weit ist oder sich zumindest ansätze
eine theorie der wind das ist zum
beispiel der originelle hausarbeit und
das wollen wir heute machen
so sei aus und in der zeit hat er gelebt
17 jahrhundert und er hat einen versuch
über den menschlichen verstand
geschrieben jetzt geht es den leitfragen
als red john law keine theorie von
handlungs wurde von blizz freiheit das
ist die wichtigste frage wie verhalten
sich wille und verstand nach block zu
einem
und jetzt gehen wir hier mal einfach mal
mitten im text hinein
die folien stelle ich dann auch noch auf
die lukas also woher die idee der
freiheit notwendigkeit stammen sagt wohl
jeder findet in sich selbst eine kraft
bestimmte handlungen in sich anzufangen
oder zu unterlassen fortzusetzen oder
abzuschließen
aus der betrachtung des umfangs dieser
macht des geistes über die handlungen
des menschen die jeder in sich selbst
findet entstehen die ideen von freiheit
und notwendigkeit
also was ist jetzt hier nach sherlock
freiheit und was ist jetzt für john lobb
notwendigkeit woran bemisst sich diese
unterscheiden was ist hier der zentrale
begriff bei glock
was ist das signalwort das zauberwort
hier das wichtigste wort das ist auch
wichtig wenn sie eine hausarbeit
schreiben das in den jeweiligen zutaten
die wichtigsten begriffe erkennen
es gibt immer in jedem zitat eigentlich
ein haupt begriff um denen alle anderen
begriffe kopiert sind
was würden sie jetzt sagen ich habe es
hier der zentrale begriff
scheint mir auch sondern also eine kraft
und er sagt auch dann noch weiter der
dritten zeile eine macht kraft und macht
könnte auch sagen vermögen ein vermögen
die kraft anzufangen oder zu unterlassen
fortzusetzen oder abzuschließen
also betrachten des umfangs dieser macht
des geistes über die handlung des
menschen
jeder in sich findet entstehen ideen von
freunden notwendigkeit also was wäre
dann die idee der freiheit wäre dann
umformuliert blick auf den griffen kraft
wäre das dann könnte man freiheit dann
definieren
definieren sie mal bestimmen sie mal
freiheit mit dem begriff die kraft
also ganz einfach einfach
eben kräftig seiner kräftig sein in sich
das vermögen spüren die kraft zu haben
und die idee der notwendigkeit wäre eben
dann müssen wir das über die kraft
definieren kraftlos wäre das
notwendigkeit
er könnte sich auch die idee vorstellen
ich habe die kraft in mir aber die kraft
reicht nicht es gibt noch stärkere kraft
die meine innere kraft aufhebt gibt zwei
möglichkeiten entweder wir sind kraftlos
oder wie es haben die kraft aber wir
sind nicht stark genug um gegen eine
andere kraft die uns da irgendwie
determiniert anzugehen
es müssen jetzt mal noch mal offen
halten also irgendwas die nicht
ausreichende kraft wäre dann die
unfreiheit ob die unfreiheit dann auch
die notwendigkeit ist ist die andere
frage
die kraft des geistes in jedem
augenblick eine einzelne von diesen
handlungen ihre unterlassung vorzuziehen
oder umgekehrt dass diejenige fähigkeit
die wir wie schon gesagt den willen
nennen die tatsächliche betätigung
dieser kraft nennen wir die
willensäußerung die unterlassung oder
ausführungen jene handlung auf einen
solchen geistigen akte bevorzugung hin
nennen wir willkürlich so gewinnen wir
die ideen der freiheit und notwendigkeit
sie entstehen aus der betrachtung des
umfangs dieser macht die der geist und
zwar nicht nur der geist hat sondern das
gesamte handeln gewesen der ganze mensch
über die handlungen hat
jetzt kommen wir so ein paar begriffe
ganz wichtige begriffe ins spiel
der begriff des willens der begriff der
willensäußerung der begriff die willkür
kann können wir die begriffe hier schon
hinreichend unterscheiden oder noch
nicht was würden sie sagen was ist der
wille
ne
der wille ist offensichtlich noch keine
kraft des geistes
also man könnte eigentlich sagen ein
vermögen auch so ein bisschen die
möglichkeiten die kraft ist ja nur wenn
sie mal überlegen wie sie kräftemessen
in der physik kräftemessen sie zum
beispiel über so einen newtonmetern also
wenn sie da sein also kräfte messen sich
zum beispiel auch übergewicht über die
anziehungskraft also kräfte könnte man
sagen messen sie auch mit potenzial wenn
sie eine feder zusammendrücken eine
feder dann ist da eine kraft angelegt
die wirken könnte als ein betrag der
aber noch nicht unbedingt wirken muss so
lese ich das jetzt als ein vermögen
die möglichkeit und jetzt sagte die
tatsächliche gleich die tatsächliche
ausführung jeder handlung auf einen
solchen geistig akt der bevorzugten hin
wenn wir willkürlich also willkürlich
wäre dann nach lockt etwas faktisches
also etwas konkretes also die ausführung
des willens
die entscheidung die handlungs wirksame
entscheidung dieses bildes oder
st
sie würden sagen er noch die
möglichkeiten die handlungsmöglichkeiten
müssten hier reinkommen
ja das ist ein guter punkt wir müssen
gleich weiter lesen aber auf 1 punkten
möchte noch hinweisen nämlich dass er
sagt wer ist denn jetzt hier das subjekt
der freiheit
schauen sie mal die letzten zwei drei
zeilen hier und das ist glaube ich ein
verdienst von john lobb dass er darauf
hingewiesen hat man könnte jetzt also
wer ist jetzt frei also wer ist
eigentlich frei die kraft der wille die
willkür der geist der mensch also das
ist ein großes verdienst von lok und das
steht auch in einer diese
randbemerkungen diese ausgabe die ich
ihnen zugeschickt habe das sehen sie
immer am rand zu kurzfassung an einer
randbemerkung sehen sie dann
ich glaube dass das auch im logischen
originaltext im englischen so ist sagt
er
kräfte dürfen nicht personifiziert
werden oder sowas oder vermögen dürfen
nicht essentially siert werden also es
ist immer der gesamte mensch der durch
seinen willen frei ist aber nicht der
wille ist eigentlich frei und der geist
ist auch nicht frei ist und der mensch
als ganzes weil man redet häufig soja
willensfreiheit handlungszeit da ist der
wille frei der wille wäre der akteure
und der wille ist kein akteur pille ist
ein vermögen eines akteurs einer
substanz und einer person und nun
zusammen spielen diesem lebendigen
kontext überhaupt kann dann diese person
frei sein
also hier können sie auch schon mal
sehen wäre auch interessante frage von
der hausarbeit die frage nach dem
subjekt der freiheit wer ist am ende
oder war es am ende eigentlich vollzogen
hat doch der menschliche person alle
tätigkeiten von denen wir eine idee
haben reduzieren sich wie gesagt auf die
zwei des denkens und der bewegung
folglich ist der mensch jetzt spricht
der für mensch und nicht vom willen und
der handlung insoweit frei alter die
kraft hat gemäss der wahl oder
bestimmung des eigenen geistes zu denken
oder nicht zu denken sich zu bewegen
oder nicht zu bewegen
sobald man ausführungen oder
unterlassungen nicht gleichermaßen in
seiner macht hat sobald das tun oder
nicht tun nicht gleichermaßen auf die
bestimmte entscheidung des geistes folgt
ist man nicht frei obwohl die handlung
vielleicht willkürlich ist das ist jetzt
eine spannende frage das müssen wir noch
klären
so ist die idee der freiheit die die
eine macht die ein handelndes wesen hat
irgendwo irgendeine einzelhandlung zu
vollziehen oder zu unterlassen
gemäß der entscheidung oder dem gedanken
des geistes wobei eines dem anderen
vorgezogen wird wo das handelnde wiesen
nicht die macht hat dass eine von beiden
seine willensäußerung gemäss zu bewirken
da fehlt ihm die freiheit ein solches
wesen unterliegt der notwendigkeit
freiheit kann also nicht dort sein wo es
kein denken keine willensäußerung keine
willen gibt wohl aber können denken
wille willensäußerung da vorhanden sein
wo es keine freiheit gibt eine kurze
betrachtung von einigen naheliegenden
beispiel möge das erläutern
das ist jetzt ein sehr zentrales zitat
als es scheint für ihn dass freiheit
immer mit alternativen möglichkeiten
oder mit genau genommen zwei
möglichkeiten das sammlung ich kann oder
auch nicht tun
entweder oder
so kann nicht nur immer nur eines wollen
können oder tun können sind ich muss
auch immer die unterlassung tun können
wie verstehen sie jetzt diesen satz
ihren sobald man
wo ist noch mal schauen genau wird der
zeile 42 34
sobald man ausführung oder
unterlassungen nicht gleichermaßen in
seiner macht hat sobald das tun oder
nicht tun nicht gleichermaßen auf die
bestimmende entscheidung des geistes
folgt ist man nicht frei obwohl die
handlung vielleicht willkürlich ist wie
verstehen sie jetzt das also es ist
möglich dass eine handlung wie möglich
ist ohne dass sie frei ist
wie kann man das verstehen ist das nicht
eigentlich ein widerspruch willkürlich
könne doch meinen dass es eben auch aus
freiheit
nur
für die frau
[Musik]
wir haben aber er sagte hier dass die
handlung willkürlich ist
[Musik]
ich glaube es gegen die richtige
richtung
mich hat dieser fall jetzt erinnert an
diesen fall bei harry frankfurt in
seinem zweiten aufsatz über alternative
möglichkeiten
kennen sie noch diesen zweiten aufsatz
über das prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeiten über das php wo er in
frankfurt sagte das php ist falsch und
was war denn da noch mal der kerngedanke
dahinter können sie das noch mal sicher
sich erinnern
[Musik]
die 1
genau
könnten sie das jetzt mit diesem punkt
zusammenbringen würde das jetzt passen
dass man das bei frankfurt dieses php
dass das falsch ist diese identifikation
dass man das in diesem willkürlich
zusammen bringt also ließ ich es
jedenfalls also dass man ja
die sollte sie gar nicht und was machen
die wahl zu gehen und man ist
hier also ließ ich jetzt also ich glaube
unter uns dass harry frank hat das von
john locke übernommen hat also ich
glaube dass diese gedanken hätte dass
das php falsch ist dass sich das auf
dieses zitat bezieht auf diesen gedanken
jedenfalls ne also es kann sein dass wir
uns für etwas entschieden haben aber
letztendlich das ist dieses beispiel bei
harry frankfurt ich entscheide mich mit
der s-bahn herunterzufahren heute in die
stadt
und ich kann mich aber eigentlich gar
nicht anders entscheiden weil es da
diesen bösen professor gibt der mein
gehirn so manipuliert hat dass wenn ich
was anderes entschieden hätte dass das
dann manipuliert hätte also ist über
determination und was also möglich dass
ich etwas will etwas willkürlich dabei
aber eben nicht die alternativen
möglichkeiten habe das auch nichts zu
tun was für john lockt die voraussetzung
für freiheit lassen also wenn wir die
andere alternative genommen ist aber ich
die andere alternative eben gar nicht
will in meinem willkür aktion eben nur
die eine mögliche dann wäre das
willkürlich aber eben nicht frei weil
die andere alternative mir nicht zur
verfügung steht so könnte man das lesen
das wäre jetzt also ganz in diesem sinne
von harry frankfurt dass dieses php
nicht notwendig ist um
naja wir müssen sagen willkürlich
jedenfalls genannt werden zu können
frankfurt spricht ja dann tatsächlich
von freiheit und das würde jetzt hier
jedenfalls lockt nicht tun
naja schwierige frage habe er
unterscheidet jedenfalls freiheit von
willkürlichkeit muss man noch mal weiter
darüber denken alles geht immer um die
frage nach der
handlung zu vollziehen oder zu
unterlassen immer dieses entweder oder
also es gibt wirklich die
entgegengesetzte möglichkeit und die
scheint bei der willkür nicht notwendig
zu sein weil es sagt ja hier in der
mitte dass man wenn man diese
unterlassung nicht in seiner macht hat
könnte dennoch und man nicht frei ist
könnt ihr noch die handlung willkürlich
sein weil man eben eine option gewählt
hat und die eben dabei nicht eben
abhängig ist von der andere möglichkeit
es war ein bisschen weiter lesen einen
tennisball gleichviel ob er durch den
schlag eines tennisschläger in bewegung
versetzt ist oder sich im ruhezustand
befindet geld niemand für ein frei
handeln das wesen wenn wir nach dem
grunde fragen zu liegt offenbar darin
dass wir einen tennisball kein denken zu
schreiben
und darum auch bei ihm kein wollen kein
bevorzugen der bewegung gegen die beruhe
und oder umgekehrt annehmen aus diesem
grunde hat er keine freiheit ist kein
freihandel das wesen vielmehr fällt
beides seine bewegung wie seine ruhe
unter unserer idee des notwendigen und
wird auch so genannt ok als notwendig
ist das wo eben hier keine bevorzugung
kein wollen keine alternativen
handlungsoptionen folgen
ebenso hat ein mensch der ins wasser
fällt weil eine brücke unter ihm bricht
keine freiheit ist kein frei handelndes
wesen
denn obgleich einen willen hat und das
nicht fallen die im fallen vorzieht
versteht doch die unterlassung jena hat
bewegung nicht in seiner macht das auf
seine willensäußerung hin eine
unterbrechung oder ein aufhören dass
neben nicht erfolg er ist also in dieser
hinsicht nicht handlungswillig frei ist
das schon
da kann es schon anders wollen die frage
ist ob in diesem fall wenn die brücke
unter dem zusammenfällt ob er da
überhaupt noch den willen wirklich haben
kann
nicht nur den wunsch weil er gar keine
potenzielle möglichkeit hat oder wenn
ein mensch sich selbst oder sein freund
durch eine krampfartige an bewegung die
durch willensäußerung oder aufführung
seines geistes hin zu hemmen oder zu
unterlassen nicht in seiner macht steht
ein schlag versetzt so denkt niemand er
sein diese sinnvolle frei jeder bedauert
ihn weil er dann notwendig unter
notwendigkeit und zwang handelt jetzt
stellen sie mir vor sie unterbricht die
brücke zusammen und sie haben jetzt aber
den willen herunterzufallen
sind sie dann noch frei er ist jetzt der
punkt sind sie dann noch frei eben nicht
aber sind sie willkürlich darin ja würde
würde locker sind darin willkürlich also
eben dieselbe option haben aber sie
haben keine alternative und es ist so
ein bisschen der punkt bei harel
frankfurt mit dem php wenn sie wenn die
brücke unter ihm zusammen stürzt und sie
das auch wollen
dann reicht das nachher in frankfurt um
frei zu sein obwohl sie keine
alternativen möglichkeiten haben und das
scheint lockt mit dem willkürlichen zum
einen also mir scheint hier in diesen
passagen grad eine bar eine grundlage
für frankfurts idee der falschheit des
php s zulegen
mit diesem willkürlicher nehmen wir
gerne an an fest schlafen der mensch
werde in ein zimmer gebracht in dem sich
eine person befindet die ihr zu sehen
und zu sprechen wünscht werde dort fest
eingeschlossen so dass es ihm unmöglich
ist herauszukommen erwacht ist erfreut
sich hin so angenehmer gesellschaft zu
finden und bleibt gerne da das heißt sie
bleiben dem weg gehen vor
ich frage nun ist sein bleiben nicht
willkürlich wohl niemand würde das
bezweifeln dennoch leuchtet es ein dass
jeder mensch weil er fest eingeschlossen
ist nicht die freiheit hat nicht zu
bleiben dass er nicht die freiheit hat
wegzugehen freiheit ist also nicht eine
idee die die willensäußerung das
vorziehen betrifft die betrifft vielmehr
die person in deren macht versteht gemäß
der wahl oder verfügung des geistes
etwas zu tun oder zu unterlassen
unsere derzeit reicht so weit wie diese
macht aber nicht weiter
info hindernis diese macht dieser macht
schranken setzt oder ein zwang die
möglichkeit des handels oder nicht dann
jetzt aufhebt da wird sofort die
freiheit und uns entwickelt von ihr auch
da haben sie jetzt das beispiel als sie
sind ja gerne in diesem zimmer
sie wollen bleiben das ist willkürlich
weil sie ihren willen als willkürlich
könnte man übersetzen identifikation mit
dieser mit dieser mit dieser handlung
mit diesem zustand identifikation
aber sie sind nicht frei weil sie nicht
anders könnten sie wären nicht frei weg
zu gehen sie sind eingeschlossen diesem
zimmer und das ist letztendlich mir
scheint dieser fall des php es bei
frankfurt in dem zweiten text den wir
gelesen haben in diesem semester also
freiheit oder unfreiheit und
willkürlichkeit sind miteinander
kompatibel das heißt also
willkürlichkeit und unfreiheit 13
kompatibel ist nicht genau dasselbe wie
bei harry frankfurt weil eben john lobb
für freiheit immer noch die alternativen
möglichkeiten braucht und das ist bei
harry frankfurt nicht mehr notwendig
also frankfurt würde wenn ich es recht
versteht das was lockt unter
willkürlichkeit versteht unter freiheit
verstehen und dann gleich sagen
alternative möglichkeiten sind nicht
notwendig und das ist ein sehr gutes
beispiel
und das ist glaube ich auch ein guter
schlusspunkt und die der anlass noch mal
hier was zu sagen über eine hausarbeit
sie sehen jetzt schon lok bringt jetzt
hier in mustergültiger weise beispiel
entwickelt beispiel um seine these zu
verdeutlichen
und das können sie auch immer versuchen
in ihren hausarbeiten dann zu tun sich
zu überlegen wie kann ich jetzt meine
these denn jetzt genauer expliziten
überlegen sie sich ein mögliches
szenario in dem eben dieser fall
auftritt für den sie argumentieren und
um mit diesem beispiel dieses diese
these zu verdeutlichen
wir sind jetzt natürlich noch nichts mit
durchgekommen
sie sehen wir setzt auf folie 18 und ich
geh jetzt mal weiter und wir haben hier
noch bestimmt 20 weitere folien wir
werden deinen nächsten
zum weitermachen ich möchte sie nur auf
diese eine these noch von block
hinweisen nehme ich die freiheit
betrifft nicht den willen das wäre zum
beispiel auch ein ideales zitat um einen
obertitel zu ergeben also was können sie
zb den haupttitel ihrer ihres titels
einbeziehen
zitat und im untertitel irgendwie bis
nächsten weiter explizit das ist die
hauptthese die wir behandeln wollen
warum kann freiheit nicht den willen
betreffen
warum können wir nicht willensfreiheit
sein wenn es frei sein müssen ist sogar
noch stärker gesagt der begriff der
willensfreiheit eigentlich unsinnig
warum ist ja ein widerspruch nach
schongau
das wollen wir in der nächsten sitzung
noch ein bisschen weiter behandeln dann
bis zur nächsten sitzung